طبعا يوجد ثلاث مستويات في المستوى
الاكاديمي اللي يصدر من بحوث علميه محكمه
او كتب في المستوى الاخر ومستوى الثاني او
مراكز الفكر في
المدن الرئيسيه بالذات في واشنطن هولندا
والمستوى الثالث الكتاب الصحفييه امراه
توقف كثير عن الكتابه الصحفيه لان غالبا
الكاتم الصحفي همم
يحاول يقدم وجبه سريعه الى همم
المتلقي همم مستوى الكتب اهتم بالتاريخ
اكثر من اي شيء اخر همم البحوث العلميه
المحكمه همم يعني
حاولت قدر الامكان انها تلملم همم
الافكار المتناثره هنا وهناك بالذات في
صوره الاسلام السياسي في المملكه
نشرت همم نشاط بشكل كبير
نشرت الكثير من الابحاث غير مكتمله همم
اذا جينا لابرز الابحاث اللي نشرت في
سنوات الاخيره ناخذ كتاب مش صح ولا سيف
الله كرواه اللي تكلم عن الاسلام السياسي